that's a flashlight all kerfuffled I
don't want to go like this or maybe I do
want to go like this hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome back to
the Brookhaven experiment now I don't
know if we're gonna get to the very end
of this but I'm gonna make a lot more
progress
hi I'm gonna get to you in a second I'm
gonna see you at the end of the game
we're gonna have a nice Tea Party and
then you can go [ __ ] yourself all right
so let's get back into the campaign now
obviously we left off at a good point in
the sewers and that means that we're
gonna have fun what stuff sang them on
forests but obsolete it's gonna get
harder and harder as this goes on and
hopefully I Rika jiggered my set up so
that hopefully it's a little bit better
than it was before you can see the that
one's just a little bit higher they
should be tracking just a little oh now
you're gonna stop me and so [ __ ] on me
okay oh oh that's a good sign oh I'm
happy about that all the feelings of
emotions are evacuating out my bowels oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy okay anyway I
need to get more weapons cuz good god
I'm not I'm sucking it up a lot on new
area I'm gonna start with the laser say
because I'll be goddamned if I'm gonna
be [ __ ] over by any of this [ __ ]
wait buff upgrade god dammit I forgot
about that
alright the stun grenade gives off a
blind
going out on sorties everyday rescue the
flames going what wait there's people
that come down here on a regular basis
just to keep the fires going for once in
a horror game you actually explain why
there's fire
I'm so happy whoa it's a parade of
babies operator [ __ ] babies what you
think you're doing please well [ __ ] here
oh they're sneaking up on me oh I see
something way back there ah muzzle break
I don't know what that does whoo they're
all over me okay can't spin in a circle
because I've done that before whoa well
that doesn't sound good
ah damn it
I'm fine okay oh man I can't believe
they finally justified a goddamn reason
there's a glow stick there's a monster
and for whoo oh hello man hello again
you think they would have done a better
job of lighting up the goddamn fires I
still can't see [ __ ] in here oh man I
guess I can't complain I didn't think
anyone would dedicate any sort of human
resources to be able to just light some
goddamn fires in a zombie infested
hellhole
okay that's refiling a lot more than I
remember
okay one coming down there so far so goo
goo I like it goo goo what you doing you
better not come any closer
oh no really give it to you oh that was
a warning shot it's a good thing I'm
incredibly stupid nope still miss there
we go
oh that's oh [ __ ] off no I just realized
I'm standing in a pile of Filth I don't
want to have a potty mouth oh there we
go let's skip that thank you
I know what I'm all about I know what
I'm about and I'm about a lot of skill
boink I'm not about taking any damage
but at least I got a muzzle break maybe
there's something else down there but
I'm not a biome oh that's right I didn't
get the goddamn what I need to do
greatly reduce recoil I'll take that
I'll definitely take that and the
extended clip that's what I was hey
that's kind of cool
that makes my gun look all nice neato
boink
okay maybe that'll be useful for looking
down the hallways so I can get some
illumination on whatever they're the
gift boxes that you're not coming near
me oh you're still coming near me okay
oh no ahhh
hey how's it going
damnit okay well this is incredibly
terrible and I hate everything my life
is in shambles
where are ya oh yeah good that's not a
good sound who did that who did it who
the [ __ ] did that someone over there hmm
my face oh good good I can't see a [ __ ]
just [ __ ] who's doing why don't you
get so close to me goddamnit don't stand
so close to me hawkman [ __ ] hell Oh
God Oh God oh good god he'll be with you
in a goddamn second oh jeez this got all
sorts of worse I thought I heard
something okay
oh [ __ ] god damn it he goofed up my gum
ah my guns all goopy okay this is way
harder oh this is definitely harder
oh I'm not about this I see you over
there there you are okay Wow
holy [ __ ] balls and ass [ __ ] this is
getting intense here we go well let's do
it oh man
oh mama Jamba oh mama PO Pamba whoa
Nelly okay so I can duel I can do
without that I can do without that
because apparently I think they change
it so I don't I'm not completely blinded
when I'm low on damage which is a nice
change if they did that okay Bob
standard armor-piercing do the extra
damage go through multiple targets that
sounds awesome
do I have a limited amount of that or I
just have unlimited cuz that's amazing I
want that okay what happened to my
illumination flares I had three of those
out whatever can't complain now Oh
bullet go flying nice okay stun grenade
I don't I don't
ooh okay where's there's got to be like
uh
gotta be like an ammo or uh okay looking
for the ammo looking for the helpful
help e helper turns that are gonna give
me a brand new gun where are you where
the [ __ ] are you that's way better about
the recoil by the way it's way better
about the recoil way way way better ah
Oh grody alright where are you at way
down there
alright I don't see I don't see another
prey I'm really trying to look for it
now I'm really trying to look for them
okay whoa that's a big guy down there
I love that lower recoil love just
checking to see if I got any surprises
around here
anybody whoa
well what is that oh [ __ ] [ __ ] okay hang
on he jumped over my block whoa [ __ ] off
with you oh [ __ ] okay we got incoming
but we got okay got nailed him okay who
you think you is
huh who you think you is trying to whoa
whoa can I dodge it can I dodge that hey
buddy okay so far so good doing good on
battery yes killing it killing it
killing it killing them taking a drink
of water killing zombo's requires a lot
of energy and these levels just so
happen to me much more involved okay so
I'm gonna just I'm gonna heal up my
health because this is getting pretty
dicey and I don't wanna I don't wanna
have to worry about getting hit to death
this late into the level all right cuz I
imagine that if you die you got to start
the level all over again which is gonna
be a a huge problem later
and those armor-piercing rounds that's
[ __ ] amazing that's [ __ ] awesome
light the closest enemy is not always
the most dangerous I know that whoa
who's down there
whoa what is that whoa what is that what
are you butthole
whoa jeez oh it's the thing from
penumbra oh geez geez yeah you better
run away [ __ ] you dude [ __ ] you you're
floating butthole oh geez oh geez oh
geez oh geez
that's right back off whoa whoa mark you
know likey Mark II no likey at all okay
any crates into crates
looking for crates looking for friendly
wild [ __ ] okay whoa who's doing that
[ __ ]
who's ooh whoa no nope
you're dead down there you all dad I
just wanted to learn you a lesson
real bad hey come here look at this does
that smell like gunpowder to you where
you at
there you go Oh big guy well I'm sponge
I'm gonna [ __ ] what's happening jeez
oh geez that's bad [ __ ] up with you holy
[ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you and you
and you holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] balls [ __ ]
and ass back who's doing it I'm not a
battery no it slipped I don't know why
oh good I'm so sorry you're worried
about me I'm so sorry that I have to
spend my whole goddamn life in this
[ __ ] hellhole that you put me in oh
man all right that was nuts
oh it's nice that was nuts
that was that was no joke that was nuts
a no scab i scammed a lot of ammo but I
didn't get a new gun
I'd really like a new gun okay reservoir
it is comfy oh boy everything's still
good on the recording everything's still
good probably I'm gonna assume that
that's a yes probably definitely oh
where am I oh okay hang on let me get a
good look at what I know good so there's
gonna be at least one worm that's gonna
try to crawl its way up my butthole well
hopefully I won't have to worry about
that too much kind of looks like a scene
from the left for dead oh boy
alright but other than that oh I need
that I need the fire rate like I would
love to have the uh I would love to
all right I would love to have the who
other things that's beautiful what was
that
Rama Kali looks like you're out of the
storm drain yeah aha taking your
surroundings and what's safe to move
find your way to the bridge are you
thinking yeah you'd think I'd move right
away you'd think you think that'd be a
good old whoo-whoo Hey nope all right
whoa we got close quarters here I'll
tell you what [ __ ] [ __ ] you what the
[ __ ] he was just standing there oh he's
waiting for me to kill him oh he wanted
the sweet embrace of death and I was
happy to provide poof oh man oh man
who's getting this is getting legit like
scary [ __ ] with you who's getting legit
wow it's so legit scuri what is there's
something down there okay okay I gotta
save my battery I'm being bad about that
I only got 87 left I mean I didn't take
any damage but at least you know I got
through it okay oh man oh this games
starting to get my heart going
get out of here we got things to do did
something happened out here I was
worried that something fell down I
thought I heard a noise in real life but
apparently it was not okay everything's
fine everything's fine mag ammo I wish I
had a mag did it wait did I get a gun I
didn't actually see what I got when I
shot that case did I get a gun Oh Maggie
no Maggie no I got a megiddo Oh
ammo for the Megiddo but I got it I'll
get you later next time I'm gonna stick
with this because I got a lot of bullets
for it so now I don't need to be
wasteful all right I I can't be wasteful
I I don't need to be conservative not
that I've been conservative at all I've
been very much [ __ ] about my bullet
usage but you know it's fine you're on
the lookout for a weapon an upgrade
crate shoot them to acquire new gear
yeah I know that now
whoa what the [ __ ] with you Jesus Oh God
okay well where is he come I am slam bam
bam bam wham bam thank you ma'am [ __ ]
whoa hey [ __ ] off damage caught that guy
just a little bit too late
whoa hey hey buddy do you have two heads
no you have no heads oh [ __ ] what's that
oh [ __ ]
you know these are piercing rounds don't
really pierce as much as advertised whoo
[ __ ] off gun oh damn it that's really
close
come on Oh who's [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] shoot oh man this is not going
too well [ __ ] I think I gotta shake it
off it's not what I was doing I wasn't
doing the thing with the shaking no no
no no I will dodge you all day all day
mother humper ha Oh all day mother
humper all day mother humper oh I don't
care
time crisis go full time crisis on you
[ __ ]
it's where you go that did not work but
you can assume that that went well and
then assume also that I was cool [ __ ]
dad
Wow okay not with the mag because I
don't want to be left out in the lurch
and nothing does that I don't know if
it's gonna be snoring I'm smart enough
to switch a weapon on me oh that's not
the gun I want that's that's not the gun
I won Oh that'd be nice that'd be nice I
just don't have enough bullets unless
now I don't have enough bullets I got
too many small things to waste ammo on
that hunk of loin huh blowing blowing
huh blowing blowing boy oh boy okay whoo
Nellie Wow who's getting [ __ ] I get I
get so turned around last time okay fire
an illumination flare into the sky for
better visibility Wow that'd be nice to
know but I didn't know that and I didn't
use that I've never used one before in
my life
sorry over there that guy was hard to
hit they save the ammo save the ammo mmm
I keep thinking something's gonna
whoo-whoo-whoo [ __ ] cow
there we go you do shake it you do shake
it who's in there
oh [ __ ] okay got something
Oh oh [ __ ] that's a lot of spiders
coming from in there okay so far so goo
who's up
who's doing that whoo [ __ ] whoo [ __ ]
goddammit I keep thinking from above not
above from the side from the side
who's gonna scatter here Scott
that's right get down oh not above okay
I'm like a cowboy cowboy
except them about to die okay whoo [ __ ]
didn't know how to have to be dodging
nothing here let me make sure that I'm
not oh my god damn oh [ __ ] I get a drink
alright sorry about the little breather
I needed but goddamn it was getting
intense okay but I don't have that
luxury I'm gonna use the illumination
player this time I'm gonna used it right
off the bat so that I have it come on
give me where is it that's not it
that's where where's my no no wait how
do I wait what wait no don't so close
many don't quit don't quit don't quit
there's no button on here that says quit
I tried to what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
kidding me what the [ __ ] was that I was
looking for the goddamn flare are you
[ __ ] serious I gotta go through all
this again [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
serious what the [ __ ] happened
I didn't [ __ ] that with Cherise you
didn't give me a goddamn choice what the
[ __ ] does that mean press again to not
quit what kind of [ __ ] [ __ ]
option is it to press to not quit it
should be press to confirm to quit not
press oh [ __ ] here's a countdown before
we exit your game and you lose your
[ __ ] progress huh there's no reason
to have oh did you mean that
we're gonna make sure but do it anyway
Oh
oh that sounds gurgly again is it a
gurgling might be oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] criminy I had to get their blood
it's what alright so far so good so far
so cool oh what a beautiful moonlit
night wonderful wonderful time to be
murdering creatures from the beyond
ah ah goddammit I see you down there
what I didn't know there's gonna be
tunes I didn't know it's gonna be do
bleh
how would I have known that it was gonna
be Michael do bleh [ __ ]
alright well carry on carry on now that
I don't have to replay a son-of-a-bitch
will carry on
oh I scrub angst a bunch oh [ __ ] man
alright woo I'm gonna keep going I just
need another drink it's getting quite
warm in y'all I can't run the air or
when I'm in here and all the lights
don't help yeah this dude is wait bridge
I'm literally going right up there why
couldn't I've taken a lengthier jaunt on
my way to Jess huh-huh okay should I try
the megiddo I'll give it a go punk the
Megiddo ago Oh silly [ __ ] Oh God
well I'll get the critical hit one
farmer fierson oh that's got a bump too
that one that's not gonna get annoying
anytime soon
alright who wants one I can't miss this
bridge will take you to Sangamon forest
can you smell the char know parts of the
forest still smolder the first breach
was torn open and peoria caverns inside
the forest we were miles away
Brookhaven we didn't know fires the
forest fires huh well smokey did warn
you blammo for Oh - get off of me
hey hey no no I [ __ ] passion no no no no
no no whoa passes got some oomph to it
but I don't know if it's gonna be good
for my man Oh one shot
holy [ __ ] oh my word
the only thing it's not good for of
those little shits I'll be with you in a
second I got to make sure there's no
little shits coming my way I need oh
it's a chest forgot for you
headshots are for losers oh [ __ ]
ah [ __ ] get back get back honky oh I I
hit him I forgot that I can melee him
with my swinging hammer oh hello I ran
right into that that was my bad line I
am loving this gun I am loving this gun
this is this is quite a home free pistol
and I like my pistols room for you I
like everything only I want more oomph
in my life and I just got to sweep the
back hand
I just got bitch-slapped the little
babies goddammit I want one of those I'm
gone with megiddo again Magnum Megiddo
why I am Who I am all right
I'm afraid to open the menu because I'm
afraid it's gonna quit on me is that
yeah I thought that oh hey Oh Lu para
Lucario holy [ __ ] that's gonna be
awesome as soon as I can get that and
get some ammo for it you died BAM
I don't even know if you were alive to
begin with but you're dead now hello oh
thanks for lining oh thanks for the
lining up let me see this oh [ __ ] you a
[ __ ] get off of me get off of me biamp
knock knock
you didn't say who's there knock-knock
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you hey my face
get it off get it off there we go
oh man I love the showers of blood whoa
judo oh I hit yeah you just didn't die
like I told you to cool ah [ __ ]
criminy with that blam
oh man this is great for people like me
that don't have a lot of skill that [ __ ]
well come here come here hug for you
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] off that guy didn't want
to die I mean I don't think any of these
guys want to die but they don't really
have a choice in the matter
hello okay first we got how to reload
for a second boy thank you I'm gonna
just switch this over to the knife it
doesn't work too well but I'm as it'll
work well in conjunction with this
because I seem that plenty of light I
don't need really a lot of light so
might as well go with the kukri does
that say titanium the Poli I had a
flashlight ooh a shotgun I forgot about
that but I don't want to risk it I mean
it can't possibly take that much ammo to
kill everybody here but I still don't
want to risk it i'ma not risky guy okay
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna I don't
even need the laser sight I'll take the
muzzle break actually I'll take that I
need the extended clip is what I call
reversing
[ __ ] you balls those I call that
grenades the [ __ ] you balls when aiming
focus on the front of the gun set
instead of the target
I don't know I'm gonna look the target
dead in the eye when I kill them and
then tell his family that of the dirty
deeds that I've done where are ya I
can't see ya
where're ya huh oh [ __ ] oh I'm good
hang on I'll be right with you sir guy
clear the forest out of these buggers
here whoa [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] off
oh this is getting [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] why doesn't that not work
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] off with you oh
[ __ ] oh this is a bad sign [ __ ] [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] well this is going very poorly
for me
but something whoa oh hey don't don't
don't don't don't don't
all right we're fine everything's fine
don't don't don't
is that dawn approaching am I going out
of my mind or is it starting to turn day
what was that she was saying about
losing moonlight I think it's a good
thing we're losing moonlight unless they
get really active during the day or it's
some [ __ ] like that really mmm I
sell hurry thank you what did I scavenge
and where am I going next
ooh that's a good scavenge that's a
quality scab oh the Sangamon forest it's
not quite day yet but maybe that
illumination is just a fire so anyway
that's all I'm gonna do for this episode
sorry to cut it quote/unquote short I
still know that this is a long video but
I was gonna get to the end of it but
there's a lot of levels it'll head to me
and I got God blocked by the thing
they've built the game's restarting and
me getting angry but either way that is
the Brookhaven experiment there's
probably one more episode together
before we get to the end of this place
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you okay [ __ ]
off
I love that I'm afib you're diagnosed
just like a bee